我們今天來聊一個創業故事，主角是一位叫 Dick Portillo 的先生。他在1963年開了間熱狗攤，但你知道嗎？他當時根本不會煮熱狗。
等等，不會煮熱狗還開熱狗攤？這聽起來有點荒謬吧。一般人創業不是都應該對自己的產品很了解，甚至要有些獨門秘方嗎？這怎麼可能成功？
這就是這個故事最出乎意料的地方。他從一個對烹飪一竅不通的人，最後在50年後，把這家熱狗事業發展到可以賣近10億美元給私人股權公司，自己也成了百萬富翁。
近10億美元？這數字也太驚人了。他具體是怎麼做到的？難道他後來去學了什麼厲害的熱狗秘方嗎？還是有什麼特別的行銷手法？
其實原文提到，他一開始就投入了大量的時間和精力。到2014年的時候，Portillo's 已經是美國中西部最大的私人餐廳公司，擁有4,000名員工。
沒有特許經營，也沒有外部投資，竟然能做到這麼大規模？這模式撐得久嗎？一般這種擴張速度，資金和管理壓力應該很大吧。
原文有寫，Portillo's 的成功並不是靠快速擴張或科技噱頭。他們是靠「逐步累積」的。到2014年時，其中一家分店每年就能創造高達900萬美元的收入。
900萬美元？這表示他們的單店營收非常高。但回到原點，一個不會煮熱狗的人，怎麼能讓產品賣這麼好？總不能說他的熱狗是靠「不會煮」才出名的吧？
這點其實很有趣。他的例子告訴我們，創業成功的核心可能不是你一開始就有多「專業」的技能，而是你願不願意學習，還有對市場的敏銳度。他雖然不會煮，但他可以找會煮的人，或自己學。
我猜啦，他可能更懂得經營，而不是執著於廚藝本身。就像有些連鎖咖啡店的老闆，也不一定會烘豆子，但他們知道怎麼讓店面賺錢。
沒錯，而且原文還提到，他來自貧困家庭，甚至覺得自己一無是處。這個背景反而讓他更願意努力，也更懂得從零開始。
這點我是信了。很多時候，資源匱乏反而會激發出更強的生存本能和學習能力。但對於一般的創業者或主管來說，能從中學到什麼呢？難道我們都要先「不會」做某件事再去創業嗎？
我覺得它鼓勵的是一種「即使起步不完美也能成功」的心態。對於創業者來說，是不要被自己的「專業不足」給嚇到；對於主管而言，可能是重新思考「用人」的標準，會不會太過強調特定技能。
你是說，與其找一個技術滿點的，不如找一個有毅力、學習能力強的人？這點其實不容易做到。畢竟在招聘時，技能還是很重要的評估指標。
但如果把這個概念帶入我們一般上班族的工作或生活呢？比如說，一個業務員可能對某個產品不熟悉，但他有沒有可能透過學習、觀察，甚至跟客戶的互動中，成為這個領域的專家？
好像也提醒了我們，很多時候我們把「不會」當成藉口，而忘了其實「學會」的過程本身，就是一種價值創造。